foreign
[Music]
cruelty
you've been fighting the Hurricanes for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
my father didn't believe in Revenge
we will
let me fight beside you
reload
[Music]
he said that I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him I'm fighting
for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
a prophet why is that a bad thing use it
because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the trades are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
Uncle Ruckus
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
foreign